i'm christina tozie the chef founder and
owner of milk bar today we are going to
be giving my childhood favorite peanut
butter and jelly a bake over
we are here in our los angeles milk bar
the spirit of milk bar has come in
you're welcome but i knew there was
something that we were missing you don't
actually even know all the crazy things
that we're dreaming up that don't even
make it to the menu it was just a great
idea we had it we had a great time bye
the lab is an invitation into our
kitchen and a few times a week we open
that window which is our moment where
we're bringing these ideas that have
inspired us to life
here to be my thought partner i got my
bestie over here scotty b who's the chef
of milk by lab here in la i'm talking
about peanut butter and jelly and i
think we should create something that is
our love letter to a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich there's this
textural dream that comes with the bite
of a great peanut butter and jelly
sandwich you have that sort of
cloud-like bounce of the two layers of
bread then all of a sudden you get this
burst of flavor and your mind is trying
to chase around what's happening that
sweet fruity flavor that you get from
the jelly or the jam it's syrupy it's
gelatinous when you have a bite it is
it's like fireworks in your mouth right
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
always gets the job done
we definitely have our plan and we got
to put it to the test we got to answer
some questions about layers and texture
it's a loaf cake it's a little a love
letter to peanut butter and jelly all
right let's get to work
if you're doing a play on pb and j
strawberry jam strawberry jam is the
play i agree so what do you do there i
like doing frozen so maybe starbucks
maybe right we have a plan okay so first
up the sorbet my best recommendation
when buying strawberries is the smaller
the better and the redder the better and
you want your strawberry sorbet to be as
punchy as possible pour them into your
blender and puree the heck out of them
so from there strawberry puree just into
the finest mesh sieve that you have at
home so all that you have left is the
most bright fruity strawberry puree
smells amazing in here we're gonna put
the ingredients together to make the
strawberry puree into a strawberry
sorbet base and as a stabilizer the
easiest thing to use is gelatin this
sheet gelatin is going to go into a bowl
of water and i like to add a few
ice cubes to make sure my water is nice
and cold it takes two or three minutes
so while we wait for that to happen on a
stove top we're going to heat up the
smallest amount of this strawberry puree
and just some granulated sugar we're
gonna add in
this stuff this is glucose it's an
inverted sugar corn syrup at home will
do as well
this actually helps keep the mouth feel
nice and smooth a little bit of kosher
salt and then for a little extra kick
citric acid if you don't have access to
citric acid a little squeeze of lemon
will do the only thing about lemon is
that it's going to impart a little bit
of flavor
so if you're using sheet gelatin it
should be fully flimsy almost jellified
from there you plop it into your pan and
you can see just contact to heat starts
to melt that gelatin into the mixture
and i turn it off the second that that
gelatin disappears entirely into our
mixture
standard ice cream maker whether it's a
plug in a hand turn it'll all do the
trick you're gonna pour that sorbet base
straight into the machine
and
let it rip for as ever long it takes to
bring that sorbet to this really
beautiful fluffy but frozen strawberry
sorbet state
[Music]
we can't just use peanut butter one
because we're now talking about some
sort of frozen layering right my grandma
used to always make this peanut butter
pie it was a lightened peanut butter but
it was like cream cheese base whipping
peanut butter and cream cheese almost
gives you like a
ganache right yeah and then lighten it
up with whipped cream i think that's a
super i like this yeah i grew up with
southern sensibilities and nothing is
better to me than peanut butter pie if
you haven't had it you need to get some
it's very simple it always starts with
cream cheese now most people when
they're mixing anything with cream
cheese try and add too many ingredients
together and cream cheese is really
tricky we're gonna make sure it's a nice
temperature and paddle it down first
before we start to add the other
ingredients i'm gonna add my creamy
peanut butter to the mixture i'm gonna
add half of it first just to make sure
the cream cheese doesn't start to lump
up want this peanut butter cream to be
nice and smooth give the bowl a little
scrape down and i add the rest of the
peanut butter
now that it's come together we just
sweetened the peanut butter so we're
going to use confectioners sugar
confectioner's sugar itself has a
tendency to want to clump up as well so
we're going to add the confectioners
sugar
half and then the other half
looks nice and smooth so to that last
half of confectioner's sugar you're
going to add some kosher salt it's nutty
the sweetness is starting to come out we
need to make it nice and light so that
it mimics the texture on some level of
that strawberry sorbet we're going to do
that by bringing heavy cream into the
mixture we need some vanilla extract and
i'm going to very slowly start to stream
the heavy cream into the peanut butter
mixture
until it comes together and loosens up
your real talk
the mixing of anything is like really
where it requires time and attention so
take your time
the secret when you're trying to add
whipped cream to anything is you first
have to sacrifice a small amount into
whatever it is that you want to accept
it it's really getting the mixture ready
so that i can fold the remaining cream
in my goal is not to deflate the whipped
cream i want it to stay light and fluffy
and i try to always make sure that my
spatula ends
up so that i'm not pushing the air out
of the whipped cream
so every bit of that white whipped cream
has incorporated entirely into the
mixture
[Music]
what do you think about like cinnamon
raisin bread
you get the swirl you get another pop of
sweetness from the raisins and it looks
great i mean we're basically making an
ice cream sandwich then
dude can't be mad at that dude like how
many layers does it go is there texture
in it to the roof
stack in the loaf pan it's also kind of
cheeky because
you've got a loaf pan a loaf of bread
it's a love cake let's do it
cinnamon raisin bread to me is one of
those magical things really makes me
feel like my imagination is churning i
am going to layer this cinnamon raisin
bread in the pan it is a perfect game of
bread tetris i was a very big game boy
girl in the 90s been training for this
moment all my life first layer of bread
is down i'm gonna use one quarter of
this peanut butter cream if you have an
offset spatula at home it will be really
helpful in judging that peanut butter
cream into corners of the loaf pan from
here off to the freezer for about five
minutes max alright so strawberry sorbet
is one nice beautiful even layer across
the peanut butter we're gonna add peanut
butter cream again another quarter of
the cream and it can go straight on top
of the strawberry sorbet
we're gonna use another quarter of that
peanut butter cream and do the same
thing all over again and bring it to the
freezer three to five minutes before you
finish it off
[Music]
all right
so from here this pb j loaf cake goes
off to the freezer 20 30 minutes and
slice away
it's time to take a look
tap
and pull that looks great my friends
i'm so excited
i mean that's mighty handsome i would
say it looks delicious and what's going
on here you going crunchy i threw
together a peanut brittle that i'm gonna
crush up on mine that's brilliant pb and
j is all about smooth and creamy and
rich
i love it
fantastic really smooth bro i'm crushed
yet i'll eat six portions and then be
like dinner what
all right my biggest question is
do you think it's ready to go on the lab
menu i think it's perfect ice cream 100
meats peanut butter and jelly all right
so you heard it here
peanut butter and jelly bake over into
this peanut butter and jelly loaf cake
is going to be available through
scotty's window at milk bar lab you come
up and you go are you crunchy
follow us online
at milk bar lab to figure out when that
happens if you're far away from l.a
that's okay you can get all your milk
bar faves at milfirestore.com sending a
care package sending a care package to
yourself is such a good play that's a
strong move we're here for you we're
here we'll make it for you
scotty so we will make it for you we
will be here
okay don't put that in do it again
very genuine we will make it we will
make it for you
[Music]
you